Speaker 1: Democrats in the Senate, led, of
course, by Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren,
are pushing a draft for the reconciliation
package that would include five hundred billion
dollars that would be collected from fossil
fuel companies to pay for the emissions that
they spewed out from the years 2000 to 2019.
Now, Chuck Schumer, for the record, has stayed
mum on whether or not he is going to include
this five hundred billion dollar fine, essentially
on fossil fuel companies to pay for their
emissions.
But why not write?
I mean, heck, one of the big issues we're
having with this reconciliation bill is it's
it's very expensive.
How are we going to cover the cost?
Well, if it's three and a half trillion, we
can pay for that half by putting this provision
in there.
The fossil fuel companies, as has been widely
reported, have known about the dangers of
climate change since at least the 1970s.
I've actually gone through the documents for
some reporting back when I was with the smog
blog.
And actually they do have documents going
all the way back to the 1950s where they talk
about the fact that we believe that the burning
that we're doing of these fuels could possibly
be changing the actual atmosphere.
It's remarkable.
And I know everybody says that they've known
since the 1970s.
But if you go through those documents, their
internal documents, they've actually been
concerned about this since the 50s.
It was just really confirmed for them in the
70s.
So either way, they have known about the dangers
of fossil fuel burning.
They have known what it does to this planet.
And yes, it is time for them to pay us back,
because these are missions that go out there,
these extreme weather events that we see as
a result of climate change, they cost money.
They cost lives.
And yet, instead of making these industries
pay for it, we're subsidizing them to the
tune of, I think, direct cash subsidies at
14 billion a year at this point.
This is nuts.
It's time for them to pay up.
And this draft that is not yet in the reconciliation
bill, but they want to get it in the reconciliation
bill, but this draft would absolutely be a
great start to get us where we need to be
on this issue.